[Applaudissements]
chacune et chacun d'entre nous ce soir
dans cette salle nous sommes menés au
20e siècle
nos parents sont nés au 20e siècle
parfois nos grands parents et puis pour
les plus jeunes sans doute leurs arrière
grands parents
nous avons tous appris à l'école
la singularité tragique de ce xxème
siècle qui nous a vu naître
combien il était unique dans l'histoire
humaine et que sa première moitié se
composait de guerre totale mondiale
industriel et qu'elle avait affecté des
centaines de millions d'hommes sur terre
et de femme laissant des continents des
pays des nations
épuisé et ces femmes et ces hommes
meurtris à la fois physiquement mais
aussi psychiquement
le traumatisme de la guerre se
constituent dans une proximité tout à
fait anormal avec la mort une mort qui
est à la fois violente massives et
répétées une mort que chaque jour
pendant des semaines des mois des années
l'on craint pour soi même et pour ses
proches sa famille est mort que l'on
observe que l'on voit que l'on entend et
puis parfois une mort qui en est en
capacité de donner et que parfois on
donne l'expérience traumatique de la
guerre
forge ainsi le psychisme des individus l
échange à jamais mais elle forge aussi
le psychisme des lignes qu'ils vont
former ou qu'ils ont déjà
moi j'appartiens une lignée ordinaire en
france
mes deux grands-pères ont fait la
première guerre mondiale
l'un a été fait prisonnier seule
survivante son unité
quelques semaines après le début de la
guerre il est resté captif pendant plus
de quatre ans l'autre qui avait devancé
l'appel s'était engagé mineurs étaient
grièvement blessés puis soignées et
renvoyé au front où il a fini la guerre
à verdun
vingt ans plus tard mes parents sont
devenus adultes
au cours de la seconde guerre mondiale
se croisant au hasard de l'exode et
traversant cette guerre dans deux villes
normandes particulièrement meurtri dont
l'une à l'être totalement rasé moi quand
je suis né au milieu des années 60 dans
la france dans laquelle j'ai grandi il
n'était question que de paix et de
prospérité
bien sûr à l'école j'apprenais les
guerres du 20e siècle mais c'était pas
bien différent du moyen-âge ou des
dinosaures et il aura fallu que quand
j'ai 9 ans notre instituteur nous montra
nuit et brouillard pour que je saisisse
plus ou moins consciemment qu'il y avait
quelque chose dont les adultes autour de
moi ne me parlaient pas quelque chose
qu'il est constitué et qui n'était pas
seulement la connaissance de des camps
de la mort dont il est question dans ce
film mais l'expérience de la violence
collective
et ce qu'elle faisait des êtres humains
et leur silence constituait comme un
secret cette expérience l'a sans doute
déterminer pourquoi dans mon jeune âge
adulte
j'ai décidé d'aller voir par moi-même de
chercher les coder tragédie ancienne qui
avait pu traverser la famille que ce
soit mes grands-pères et grands-mères ou
mes parents c'est ainsi que je me suis
rendu en chine pendant la révolution
étudiante puis à une époque où j'aurais
dû rester assis sagement dans les
banques qui sont les vôtres ce soir
après la chute du mur du berlin je suis
parti en europe de l'est
suivent les révolutions comme témoin et
plus tard en afrique du sud au moment de
la transition démocratique et la fin de
l'apartheid et ce chemin s'est achevée
dans sarajevo ville assiégée pendant la
guerre de bosnie où j'ai passé la
dernière année du conflit à l'issue de
celle-ci la paix était arrivé j'allais
repartir et trois jours avant mon départ
j'ai rencontré quelqu'un qui allait
déterminer de tout mon avenir s'agissait
d'une thérapeute bosniaque qui
travaillait avec des femmes bosniaques
elle aussi qui avait perdu des dizaines
d'hommes de la famille à commencer par
leur mari mais aussi leurs frères leurs
pères leurs oncles leurs cousins gt
saisis parce qu'elle me disait et quand
elle m'a proposé d'assister à une séance
de thérapie collective
je les accompagnais et ce jour là j'ai
été extrêmement impressionnés par ce que
j'ai vu et entendu
c'était dans l'immédiate après-guerre
jour d'après et je voyais contrairement
à tout ce que je connaissais jusque là
des femmes qui tentaient de construire
un récit qui les aiderait à survivre
face à l'absurdité de l'expérience
qu'elle avait traversé un récit qu'il
errait ancrerait dans la vie un récit
qui leur donnerait du sens pour elle
mais aussi pour leurs enfants
et peut-être pour chacun chacune d'entre
nous ce que j'ai compris aussi ce jour
là et ça ça allait déterminer mon destin
de cinéaste sait quel point la scène
thérapeutique est une scène de création
combien c'est une scène où on s'invente
soi même non pas contente
il n'y a pas de récit préalable et c'est
l'endroit on se crée en cherchant à
comprendre le sens de ce qui nous
construit c'est comme ça que j'ai décidé
d'introduire une caméra en thérapie en
imaginant que celle ci ne serait pas là
pour témoigner mais pour accompagner
pour participer à l'invention de ce
récit signifiant et salvateur c'est
comme ça que moi même je me suis aussi
ce jour-là inventait cinéaste
j'ai donc filmé trois femmes pendant
toute la durée de leur thérapie durant
un an
le film s'appelle de guerre lasse et je
les montre est un peu partout et chacun
ici ou là dans le monde
il trouvait manifestement des échos de
ce qu'avait été
la vie familiale au cours du 20e siècle
ça m'a encouragé à aller plus loin a
constitué en contrepoint récit masculin
qui viendrait compléter ce récit féminin
c'est comme ça que je suis parti aux
états unis à la recherche d'hommes qui
auraient fait les guerres d'irak et
d'afghanistan et qui seraient eux aussi
en thérapie ces hommes comme les femmes
de bosnie cherchait absolument à
survivent et chercher à s'ancrer dans la
vie avec un récit ayant eu ces deux
expériences aujourd'hui un peu
logiquement je prépare le troisième
volet ce qui s'appelle aujourd'hui une
généalogie de la colère et qui
constituaient de de guerre lasse et dove
men et noir des hommes et de la guerre
et qui s'intitulera l'enfance de la
guerre il est consacré à des jeunes
êtres humains qui ont traversé des
conflits des révolutions dans leur jeune
âge
avant d'arriver ici vous les croisez
quelquefois dans les villes de france où
les croisés peut-être sur les trottoirs
de cergy c'est ce qu'on appelle des
mineurs non accompagnés
je cherche à en trouver qui eux aussi
serait en thérapie est aussi chercheur
est à inventer un récit qui les
sauverait jeudi inventé non pas comme un
mensonge bien entendu mais encore une
fois comment on constitue un récit qui
n'existait pas auparavant nous tous ici
ce soir nous sommes des enfants du 20e
siècle et à ce titre nous sommes des
enfants de la guerre
consciemment ou non qu'on le veuille ou
non la guerre fait
artix du legs psychique que nous avons
reçues insidieusement elle nourrit
toutes nos névroses petites ou grandes
elle nourrit aussi la colère sourde aux
bruyantes qui est le lot de nos sociétés
alors on pourrait en rester là et se
dire c'est la fatalité on doit vivre
avec ça ne constitue moi même j'aurais
pu faire cela j'aurais pu la répercuter
aux générations suivantes
mais j'ai eu beaucoup de chance et c'est
cette chance là que je voudrais partager
avec vous ce soir aussi c'est de
rencontrer des femmes et des hommes
remarquables à la fois totalement
ordinaire est aussi hors norme des
femmes et des hommes qui avaient été
précipitées dans une béance qu'il
n'avait jamais imaginé monstrueuse et
que nous mêmes on a du mal à imaginer si
nous les entendons et pourtant ils ont
décidé à un moment donné ça n'est pas
les emporter qu'il survivrait
psychiquement aussi et que ce faisant il
permettrait à leur descendance de
survivre psychiquement et que seul le
silence
condamné à un destin mortifère alors il
savait que ça serait pas un chemin
facile que ça serait douloureux qu'il
faudrait s'y atteler toute la vie est
censé se remette sur les chevaux mais
ils ont décidé de le faire avec les
moyens qui étaient les leurs ils ont cru
qu'il existe des récits réparateur que
ces récits réparateur peuvent nous
apporter une paix intérieure et qu'ils
peuvent aussi apporter une paix
collective
merci
[Applaudissements]